you might have been depressed because
you moved away and I understand that and
you didn't bother to be there for me or
ask me if I was okay at all I did all
the time you didn't do no you were
always just like nagging me to do
things hello and welcome to split
decision I'm your host Kat Takahashi and
today we brought four ex couples to the
studio some of these couples are
reuniting for the first time some are
still seeking closure that is a lie and
some May still be in love I really just
like want to be with you you're about to
face some of the toughest most intimate
questions you've ever been asked you
guys ready all right let's do this the
first prompt is I will miss having sex
with my ex make your split decision in
three two
[Music]
one all right go ahead and turn
around Dane you say yes but Luna you say
no I will not miss having sex with my ex
why is that um I just haven't really
felt any sexual urges for anyone for a
while so it's not just him in particular
it's just not something that's been on
my mind lately mhm Dane I mean yeah I
totally would would love
to but you know I'm just going to have
to move on from that how does it feel
knowing that she's stepping on the no
right there oh it's it's no biggie you
know okay were you expecting that yeah I
was yeah yeah okay cuz I've been trying
[Laughter]
uh Ry you're no but Mia you're yes so
MIA I'd love to hear more feel like the
sex was cool for the time and I enjoyed
it but I feel like if we were to try to
revisit it now it would be weird just on
like an emotional level but like the sex
was good physically Ray why are why are
you on no um the sex was better for Mia
than it was for me just because of the
dynamic that we had specifically it was
more focused on what she wanted than
what I I wanted what was it that you
wanted that you weren't really
getting I'm a top I'm also a top yeah so
that's like what we're that's the
conversation we're having here like I
like I enjoy topping like a lot and so
like I was like switching to a commodate
and you were not as much got it yeah
yeah to be frank I wanted to strap her
more than she wanted to be
strapped that's what's happening it's
crazy that you've said that verbally
okay I'm Mia and I'm 23 my name is Ray
fizer I'm 25 um we dated for two years
we weren't compatible yeah we were
better off as friends Priscilla Victor
you both say yes I think we had a really
good sex life I'd only ever been with
one other person before him so when we
got together I was really given the
space to like explore like sexuality in
the room and new things and it was just
like a very safe and fun space for me
I'm super into like the BDSM world so
getting to like finally explore that
after like just reading about it for so
long okay was very fun for me one out of
10 how was the experience I was a 10 how
was it for you
Victor better 10 10 I just want some
suspense there yeah Ray how about you 1
to 10 how would you rate uh sex with Mia
uh like a
six a six yeah it's like not bad sex
that's all I can really say you got what
you wanted a lot more than I did my Jen
What attracted you both together so I
actually he's not my type at all so yeah
so it was only after that he grew on me
then I was like I do like taller bigger
guys yeah so then now he's very
attractive to me have it for you yeah
it's like same thing we uh we started as
best friends and then so I never got
attracted her whatsoever um and then it
just grew you know it's it's that that
love that bond that we had we were
together for 8 years and we broke up
about 3 years ago we broke up because of
trust issues and respect issues for each
other and communication okay the next
prompt is my family and friends thought
I could do better make your split
decisions in three 2
go ahead and turn
around wow wow wow interesting okay uh
Luna you say yes your friends of family
thought you could do better tell us more
my family liked Dane it was more so my
friends knowing of situations that we
had been through do you have an example
so you remember New Year's Eve in New
Orleans mhm yeah I was pretty angry what
happened we went we went to a show and
we came back and
I said something that upset him he kind
of threw a fit and he just walked out
the door and I ended up spending New
Year's alone that night at my friend's
house cuz everybody else was off doing
stuff so I was just kind of crying in
the bed by myself and had no idea where
he went just because of a small argument
that had ensued earlier okay and then so
your friends know about that kind of
stuff it you know made them think less
of him for sure I was not the best on
that New Year's and I am very aware that
her friends weren't too fond of me after
that for sure and that was just like
getting close to the end of our
relationship but my friends and family
really liked pluna you know not all of
them liked me yeah yeah know so Ray your
friends and family thought you could do
better yes um you never really met any
of my family but all of my friends think
that you took advantage of me and like
didn't appreciate all the things that I
did for you they also found out about
the PowerPoint that you made about my
red flags after our first date that's so
funny isn't that hilarious the
PowerPoint yeah she made a PowerPoint of
my red flags after our first date and
she went through it with her friends and
then we were drunk eventually I found
out and I like told my friends like haha
and they were like hey that's actually
not okay M so meia why did you say yes
the way that you would speak to me
sometimes like wasn't okay like you
almost had like no filter to a point
where you were just like being mean to
me all the time yeah that's and I was
like damn this sucks like I love you
yeah that's my fault my bad grew up in a
crazy household yeah so Sor I think you
were just like working through some
stuff and my friends just like saw how
that affected me but they love you now
the next prompt is I cheated on my ex
make your split decisions in 3 2
1 okay go ahead and turn
around Jen you're on yes yeah so we were
just really young we dated since high
school we realized that we had very
different Love Languages and then I was
just always constantly searching that in
other people but yeah like I messed up
and then I hurt him a lot cuz I'm also
his first girlfriend and everything and
so like everything like really came
crashing down hard after how how did you
find out it was like a friend that we
hung out with in a group for I think
like about 3 years or so she talked to
him and he talked to her behind my back
so then the girl that was with that guy
at the that time I found out from her
cuz she sent me me messages okay that
they deleted from each other so it hurt
like really really really bad cuz uh I'm
I'm a guy of respect you know and then
that's kind of disrespecting me and you
were in love with her yeah yeah I was I
mean she was my first and then I thought
she was my last too what was it that
made you want to cheat on him I don't
know like I always told him like when we
started being together I was like I hate
cheaters cuz I got cheated on before too
I think it was just more environmental
factors like how I am with my family
like I'm just like this perfect person
and then I think I always wanted to like
self-destruct self-sabotage but he was
like literally everything I ever had
like he was the best P like best
boyfriend he treated me right like our
love language was very different but
like I mean he loved me and I know that
he loved me but then I don't know what
happened and I like that's my biggest
regret after the cheating I tried to
make it work you know but it was still
in my mind in the back of my mind the
trust was gone is there a chance I mean
there's there's always a possibility the
next prompt is since our separation I've
been with someone who is better in bed
make your split decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 all right go ahead and turn
around so Jen after the breakup there
was someone else who was even better so
like when I was with him like that's the
best I ever had but then like when we
broke up like I was with someone that
like really loved me like really like
just gave me everything like in the
short amount of time that like for 8
years like I couldn't even feel with him
so that's why I think that love their
sex was better in the sense that it was
like love but I think that's what I was
missing from him was like I couldn't
receive love the way that he gave did
you feel that way too during the sex
like you couldn't give your love I I
thought I gave my all 100% of it cuz
that's all I knew so I I gave my 100
yeah okay Victor how do you feel that um
she's standing on yes right now that yes
she had a better experience since you I
mean good for you that's awesome yeah uh
I feel like we were always pretty sex
positive so I think uh if you're out
there having great sex like I'm not
going to hold it against you it would be
weird to uh expect her to only have bad
sex after the fact you know feel like I
kind of pushed you to date other people
yeah he kind of really did I had I had a
very negative view on relationships
after we broke up cuz I was like just
completely shattered and all my thoughts
and beliefs were pretty much
destroyed he's like you're young you're
single like get out there meet people
like leave your house we were together
for 2 years and we broke up in July of
2021 I started feeling like I wasn't
wanting to be in a relationship anymore
so yeah broke up with her
yeah the next prompt is is I never fully
trusted my ex when we were together make
your split decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 all right everybody go ahead and turn
around so Ry you never fully trusted Mia
when you were together so the second
time that we dated it was paully and it
started off with me being a secret to
one of her other partners so I didn't
know that I existed and then once found
out that I existed didn't know why I was
in Mia's life I.E we were dating um so
it just made me feel like anyone that
she brought around I didn't fully trust
that they knew who I was and why I was
around for whatever reason Mia felt like
uh she couldn't tell this person about
me Mia how do you feel about that yeah I
mean that's pretty fair I mean it was
kind of a weird situation cuz they had
kind of like asked not to be privy to
those things and we were at the time
that was like her kind of preference
with things so I just like didn't bring
it up but I was like your main so it
wasn't like we were just hooking up you
were like literally my girlfriend yeah
and she was the side you know what I'm
saying not to like break down po
relationships like that but like you
were my girlfriend like I was your
partner and she was just someone that
was a branch of other relationships
uhhuh but did this other person know
that did you communicate that to them
yes yeah everyone knew
like not everyone she knew you existed
she just didn't know like who you were
cuz she didn't want to know like I don't
know it's over you know you don't even
speak anymore so it's it's chill dude
yeah it is what it is Luna so you never
the trust wasn't fully ever there in the
beginning it was um and there was an
incident where I was using his phone as
a flashlight and a girl texted him
saying come
cuddle and he swore that nothing sexual
had happened to cause that and whether I
told myself I believed him or not I just
never could really come back from it
anything you want to say to that yeah so
like that was out of the blue for me as
well that was my girl best friend at the
time but no yeah it was a random come
cuddle and she knew that I was with Luna
and like it was just like d said she was
doing it on purpose to try I could see
it and get jealous to try and get at me
so if you felt that way then why was the
trust gone though oh no oh no that's
what you're saying that that was my
story oh I see I see I see true story
gotcha um I don't know I feel like that
could have been part of it but I didn't
know if that was the whole story how
come you don't believe him when he says
that something probably happened there I
don't know but even if it didn't like
the fact that someone had felt
comfortable enough to text him that
while she knew he was dating me still
made me uncomfortable and I could see
why her trust was gone my trust for her
would have been gone if this if the
tables were turned you know hold on this
is getting kind of spicy take a second
right now to smash that like button and
if you're really enjoying yourself how
about that subscribe button too while
you're at it let's get back into it the
next prompt is I've recently cried
thinking about my ex make your split
decisions in three 2
[Music]
1 my we recently cried over Jen huh yeah
I mean like it's not just one time it
was like multiple times just replaying
the scenarios it's like shattering you
know like you had hopes and dreams of
something that would you know be like
the end but it's not and then like every
time that I think about it it's just
it's just like heartbreaking how about
you well all the time so probably like
probably like last week or something I
don't know we always try to talk about
like getting back together cuz like
we're like almost 30 now like we should
have like a family and kids or I mean
like it's expected of me to have family
and kids but then I feel like there's so
much things that are just broken and
dented in our relationship that it I
don't think it'll go well even though I
want it to go well so if I never like
messed up in the past or if I never like
took him for granted then we would
probably still be together as you all
have like observed I'm mostly like in
the wrong in our relationship pretty
much I was really lazy and I could have
done a lot of things differently so
whenever I think about how happy I was
in our relationship and how I was really
like not the best makes me you know tear
up cry how do you feel knowing that he's
this emotional about this I feel bad I
guess I mean I feel honestly I feel
neutral over it I hate that he still
gets upset about it but it is what it is
it is what it is the next prompt is I
loved my ex more than they loved me make
your split decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around so my you loved uh Jen more than
she loved you there there were things
that she did that showed me that she
doesn't love me she's like a word of
affirmations kind of kind of person but
even though the words say that you know
she loves me it doesn't show it the
disrespect the
mistrust yeah I mean I thought I knew
what love was I thought I loved him but
of course like if you love someone you
don't really go and do that and I would
say like now I feel like I appreciate
and love him more so roles have been
reversed now but before it was
definitely him loving me a lot more
Priscilla you loved him more than he
loved you during the relationship he
initially pursued me and then as we got
more and more into it I mean he's the
one who broke up with me so obviously I
loved him more at that point he was my
forever I never saw anybody else but him
for like the one yeah he was just the
one Victor did you know that she thought
she felt that you were the one uh yeah
she would say it all the
time uh no you know what I I learned uh
something about myself in that
relationship and that was that I'm not
that much of a relationship person it
was like tough to reconcile because
while we were in it it felt like this is
such a good relationship this is so
solid like this is somebody that I
should have in my life forever but it
still wasn't like sad satisfying on the
inside like I still didn't feel like I
wanted to be in a relationship so you
haven't been in a relationship since
since we broke up I haven't dated
anybody but no he's definitely the kind
of person we mid conversation he's like
I'm done with this conversation and
that's how I felt a long time about our
relationship that he just woke up and
was like yeah I'm good about this now
Weir how did that feel when you when you
discovered that when you felt that from
him like oh he's done I remember
specifically when I felt hit it was
about 3 months before we broke up cuz we
went to the movies and I went to hold
his hand and it was the first time he
didn't hold it back and I just
instinctively knew that like something
was off and then two days after my
birthday o that's when he decided uh
Luna Dane you both say yes you both
loved each other more Dane let's start
with you you know in a relationship
you're you're you're physical with your
partner you tell them that they're cute
amazing and that you love them you
always reassure them how much they mean
to you and I never got any of that from
Luna which made me it really a lie
apparently that's a lie but that's how I
felt and it just like threw me off in
our relationship for sure I tried to say
positive things to you but if you didn't
hear them that's what was it you didn't
hear like things that made me feel
appreciated or important you know and so
why do you say yes Luna actions speak
louder than words I just feel like I
made more sacrifices for our
relationship and I just don't like felt
like my I didn't feel like my energy was
matched by Dane think they both have
like different Love Languages cuz I feel
like you probably have words of
affirmation so you need that and then
that's probably what she like you
thought she was lacking CU that's how me
and I was also going to say that we both
have different perspectives of love and
it's just like it doesn't work because
we can't give each other what we each
other need you know you like telling me
you love me and I'm beautiful doesn't
equate to me asking you for help in a
certain area of our relationship and
like over and over and over again
definitely feel like that went unnoticed
in our relationship still and you still
don't even notice them what kind of
sacrifices like moving all the way from
Florida to live in Alabama so she could
be closer to her family and you're the
one who like you wanted to move in
together the most you wanted to make
that move initially I don't I think you
wanted to make the move the most but I'm
not I'm I don't want to I don't want to
do this right now this is this is the
place to do it I feel like yeah I'm the
one who got the apartment I went and
worked and I found I didn't go work at
all or make any money or put in or
contribute to any of that I know you did
a lot but I just felt like I I did feel
like I was doing more did you feel like
you were doing more I didn't feel like I
was doing more I felt like we were
equally like striving for something I
feel like it was equal for a while there
but until I realized that she didn't
feel the same way and then I stopped
trying as
hard I see
Reay you want to share your experience
there was a period of time where I would
literally bend over backwards for you
and like run across all the Seas to like
make you happy and I didn't feel any of
that back I like thinking about it right
now I can't think of a single thing that
you ever did for me that was
specifically like for me like just to
make me happy I think you loved how much
I loved you more than you actually loved
me I didn't feel loved by you until
honestly like recently I don't know it
felt like too little too late for me
like by the time you were like open and
willing to like put an effort like that
like I was already kind of like checked
out like yeah yeah yeah that entire time
though I didn't feel any from you like
you actually forced me not to say I love
you the first time I wanted to say it
cuz you could like see that I wanted to
say it and you were like hey don't say
that so then I didn't say it you didn't
you didn't want Ray to say I love you I
don't even remember how many months in
that was but it was like really quick I
felt like it was soon do you remember
actually yeah it was like only a couple
months in I want to say oh that's
interesting I don't know I was a
different person back then yeah but you
felt the love yeah I felt like yeah I
genely felt like I loved you honestly I
think we only dated for some long cuz
we're attracted to each other like
everything else was like like fine yeah
so yeah I would
agree glad we settled
that the next prompt is I made
significant sacrifices in our
relationship that went unnoticed and
unappreciated make your split decision
in 3 2
[Music]
1 go ahead and turn
around Jennifer what were some of the
those things that you did like he's just
not really used to his parents telling
him I love you and all that so then I
feel like the way that I cared about him
it was just very unnoticed because he
didn't really read how I give love the
same way like you don't tell me that I'm
pretty or you don't tell me that you
enjoy being with me um we hang out and
I'll be like oh my God I really want to
hang out with you and he's like we have
been hanging out but then we're just
like in our room like doing nothing I
just felt like he didn't really care of
how much love I gave him I mean our love
languages are completely opposite I grew
up with like a a household that you know
them saying sorry to me is like hey you
want to go eat kind of thing so it's
like never that those words so I'm not
used to it and so it it's really hard
it's like she's speaking Spanish I'm
speaking Chinese and we're trying to
like you know communicate it's not it's
not easy you know like at that time like
there's no way that to recognize it we
weren't mature enough we didn't know
anything um until
now Dane so you made significant
sacrifices that you felt went unnoticed
most definitely like just all of the
love that I gave for her honestly that I
feel like it went unnoticed and
unappreciated because like it's just it
was more materialistic from her and I
felt like I had to do more things in
order for her to notice what I had to
offer yeah but the question was like
what did you sacrifice for a
relationship that I didn't appreciate me
moving all the way to from Florida just
to come live with you in Alabama but
that was something you told me you
wanted to do because you said you wanted
me to do it and I made that sacrifice to
be away from my family so you could stay
with
yours and it didn't mean anything to you
it did and that's why I tried so hard to
keep everything we had going and I did
too by that time that's when our
relationship definitely started to fail
and that's when I feel like you stopped
caring as much maybe I mean you might
have been depressed because you moved
away and I understand that I get that
but and you didn't to be there for me or
ask me if I was okay at all I did all
the time you didn't no you were always
just like nagging me to do
things you felt like the move was a big
enough sacrifice was to show your love
yeah I mean for sure and like I put us
on this really dope catering gig and I
got us both these dope jobs just because
you moved to where I was doesn't mean
you don't have to uphold your end of the
relationship anymore and I I still
upheld my end of the relation
relationship you just stopped noticing
me okay I don't want to get like into an
argument but see like that's every time
I bring like I could sit here and
apologize for my parts in the
relationship all day long and notice
everything that I didn't like do for you
but anytime that I bring up like
something I felt in the relationship you
say you don't want to argue and that I'm
wrong and that I'm not I didn't say
you're wrong you pretty much are you can
say it without saying it like sorry I'm
sorry you picture perfect
oh okay yeah Luna so like what
specifically were like these like the
adult things that you wanted him to do
that he wasn't doing it was simple
things like can you wash your
clothes can you pick up after yourself
can you after you finish cooking can you
help clean up it was like such a thing
like like I I could like finish like a
bowl of cereal and put the cereal bowl
in the sink and just run to the bathroom
real quick cuz you know it's hard to do
things when you got to use the bathroom
and she to me imately be like you didn't
wash your freaking dishes and that just
like this kind of stuff just happen so
so so so many times by the time it was
like yeah it was just I was over it it
was just always up to me to make sure
that things got done and I feel like
that was unsaid in our relationship but
it that was the way it was in your mind
that's the way it was so Ray you made
some significant sacrifices that you
felt were unappreciated unnoticed yes um
when we started dating we lived like 45
minutes away from each other and I would
drive to you every weekend you came to
my apartment once to the what like 6
months were together at that time um I
flew from overseas to see you spent like
$223,000 or $2,300 on a plane ticket and
you felt like you were doing me a favor
by not charging me rent for the month
that I was staying with you even though
I just paid like two over two grand to
come see you no I appreciate you for
driving that much like I'll admit I
didn't like your apartment and like
driving I think it's less about me doing
it than how you're responding to me
doing it like I never felt appreciate it
and Mia you're on yes as well you also
feel like you made significant
sacrifices that weren't appreciated I
think like
emotional labor emal labor have no idea
what you're talking about I don't I
honestly cannot imagine a single
sacrifice you made for a relationship is
this about our intimacy yeah that's not
a a sacrifice no but it is though cuz
it's like like it was like either it's
going to happen your way or it's not
going to happen at all bottoming is like
not something I want to do all the time
and like it I had to in order to be
intimate with you and there was no like
equalness to that whatsoever and I like
was trying to be respectful of the fact
that like you weren't comfortable with
your body at the time which is why I did
it but I'm saying that's like a lot of
emotional labor to like go through the
intimacy yeah I I'm sorry I just can't
see it that way because I don't you're
not you didn't I had such like gender
confusion it was insane and what was
going on inside of my brain and how I
felt about myself was
worlds larger than anything that you
could have been experiencing because you
couldn't go down on me I'm being honest
like there's no way in the world that
you felt as intensely about that as I
felt as intensely about how shitty I
felt about my body you're literally
telling me that how I felt about it
doesn't matter because it pales in
comparison to your journey with it it
doesn't matter but what are you
sacrificing from not topping me okay
like imagine not being able to top
someone that you love you're a top yeah
it was like my first queer relationship
and I was figuring things out and so it
was like my identity and my room for
growth was not a thing that could happen
because of like exterior circumstances
and that sucked for me and I felt like
I like you only wanted me to be a very
specific version of myself that was in
the way that you could have it and I had
to put everything that I was to the side
to accommodate that does that make sense
mm is it because sorry are you saying
that like who you became wasn't someone
that I wanted to be with yeah yeah I
would agree with that 100% okay yeah
yeah fully I think the same thing for
you to me
so the next prompt is I wish my ex and I
were still together make your split
decisions in three 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around you know Dane I'm I'm a little
surprised to see you on no after this
conversation today yeah I know I changed
my mind
today really yeah you know just like
coming out here with like my own
intentions and like just realizing that
I'm pretty like stupid for like thinking
that me and her would ever have a chance
again and just the way seeing that the
way both of us interact together this
whole trip just makes me not want to be
together with her anymore how do you
feel about that I agree we just don't
mes well anymore yeah what what you came
here today hoping for what I came on
this whole trip with Luna just to make
her happy hopefully that like she would
notice that I care enough to spend time
with her and do stuff that she wants to
do so that maybe you could get back
together yeah
but there's no happening with that so
I'm just like accepting it now and
standing on no yeah you say yes you want
to get back together um if there were
maybe I would say maybe maybe but uh
there's a lot to work on we can relate
to each and everyone's story a little
bit um a lot of it is a lot about
communication I do something for her she
doesn't acknowledge it right so I feel
like whatever I'm doing is just
worthless right what do you do for me me
though that I don't acknowledge I feel
like I always acknowledge everything I
should have ended it but I didn't know
any better and so we kind of dragged it
on further than we should and if you
could just get the Love Languages right
you think you could be together uh yeah
and the infidelity yeah I think so cuz I
feel like everyone here like the reason
why we're not together is cu like
everyone's communication is so different
like it's just so like prominent you did
love me you just loved me in a way that
I couldn't even like realize and then I
loved you but then you didn't care about
everything that I did verbally for you
like me wanting to know where your
whereabouts he thought I was nagging him
the whole time I'm like no I just want
to know where you are like just let me
know so I can like just feel safe so
you're both trying to change that to be
back together I mean I want to but I
don't know I feel like you're not really
ready for that conversation or something
yet she was my best friend she was my
girlfriend my best friend and pretty
much my family but kind of shattered
that so it's kind of hard to rebuild
but you said yes so yeah I mean like
there's always there's always room you
know there's always room but it's not
going to happen overnight kind of thing
I still need to work on myself the next
prompt is I believed we would spend the
rest of our lives together make your
split decisions in three 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around H so Victor you thought you would
spend the rest of your life with
Priscilla yeah in the beginning I did
yeah uh it's like I was saying earlier I
learned over the course that we weren't
quite compatible but in the beginning it
was I was like Head Over Heels I was
completely in love she said it herself I
I uh pursued her so just I don't know
couldn't get over myself I guess I think
it's a from the moment I saw him like he
literally took my breath away and then
when we got into a relationship I was
like oh my gosh this is what I've always
wanted like this is the exact
relationship I've always dreamt of
having and we always had that honest
communication and he kept it through to
the end because I said you know just
always be honest with me and he was when
he said that he this was something that
he wanted to do or be in anymore so he's
still one of my best friends and I will
always have love for him I'm not in love
with him anymore but that love I have
for him will never
cease Mia so you thought you were you
two were going to spend the rest of your
lives together yeah I mean I was like
young I was like 19 I was a baby um wild
like I do hope to spend the rest of my
life with you you know like I hope that
homies yeah I hope that we're homies for
like a real long time like I hope that I
get to be at your wedding and you get to
be at mine and like I don't know I
really appreciate you in my life
so so Luna you never felt like Dane was
the person I'd be spending the rest of
my life with I feel like we may have
ended up being together for a very long
time but I just couldn't really see
myself with anyone forever I don't know
and then once we neared the end of our
relationship it became more clear that
we weren't compatible living together so
it was obvious at that point I mean yeah
of course I thought we were going to you
know spend the rest of our lives
together I don't really spend time
enough time with people unless that's
like my
goal I think relationships can still be
important and not have to and in
marriage or you know lifelong
companionship yeah for sure yeah for
sure the next prompt is my ex has a
quality that will be really hard to find
in someone else make your split decision
in 3 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around
H well you know Luna just has her own
qualities about her that you know like
everybody
every other human does so I'm not
looking for qualities that Luna had in
other people anyways so I say
no yeah Mia what qualities did Ray have
that you don't feel like you can find in
anyone else you're a really dope person
I'm glad that I like found you and have
you in my life and I don't think anyone
could like fill the specific spot that
you fill in my life it's not like
a like oh I could just like put another
friend in your spot I hate that I
stepped on no it's the truth no it's
how I feel I don't want you to think
that you're not like special or anything
like that cuz you definitely like are a
good person and someone that like came
into my life and like changed it and um
in a net positive honestly even though
we went through so much but like I
thought that when we broke up I would
never find anyone that I got along with
so well and then I like did yeah so like
I just I yeah it was it was proed to me
that like it's great that you're here
but if you like weren't I don't I think
I'd be okay which I'm sure that you
would also be okay it's not on a
romantic that I like stepped here I
appreciate that you're really
supportive I think with Victor he he
just created this quality of making me
feel so safe and comfortable he was like
I felt so comfortable anytime he would
do this really reassuring thing when we
would walk through a crowd he would
always place his hand towards the back
of my neck to kind of like guide me in a
way and it was so subtle I don't even
know if you remember but I I think about
that when I'm in big crowds and it's
like I haven't found that sense of like
where I'm with someone I'm like oh I can
just like be it's
amazing uh I think Priscilla's probably
the kindest person that I've ever met uh
she's unbelievably nice even the people
that are mean to her which is probably
not a good thing but she's super nice
she's incredibly hardworking I've seen
it personally like the things that she's
done to go out of her way to take care
of her family she takes incredible care
of our dog like that dog eats better
than I do um yeah yeah she's just
somebody that you can lean on rely on
yeah no
[Laughter]
no has he never told you this you think
I'm cool that's awesome I didn't say
cool okay well maybe not cool you you
think I'm kind okay the next prompt is
I'm ready to ask you in this studio
right now will you take me back okay
everyone make your split decisions in
three two
one
okay everybody go ahead and turn
around I
tried some people are like relieved like
oh thank God not on camera oh my God
this whole trip I kind of learned that
both of us have grown into two
completely different people in the last
N9 months definitely on different path
neither of them negative just it makes
it clear to why we broke up I think it
was kind of eye opening because I feel
like every want our exes here because
they don't see eye to eye at all and
that was really the downfall of
everything with us too it's interesting
to see how how solid our friendship is
like all this time later it's cool to
just have all these questions kind of
reaffirm it well that's all we had time
for today thanks for watching this
episode of Split Decision next up we're
diving into the lives of ageg Gap
couples see you
then